many of you have watched lots of our
videos now about chemistry and I'm
really quite excited because our
colleagues in the school of physics and
astronomy have decided to make some
videos about physics about the different
symbols in physics and this going to
give me an opportunity to go over to the
physics department and look at something
that I really wanted to see for a long
time and I think you'll find quite fun
too well it's not very far but we have
to go outside but unusually for England
it's sunny so I go over to physics and
from time to time and I meet physicists
in the lab from time to time
so we have the school of chemistry over
there and in fact my lab is the one just
behind the trees over there and then we
have the school maths and physics over
here I think that there is I I think
there's friendly collaboration and then
when my grandfather and my father and my
mother-in-law and my father-in-law were
all physicists so I have physics in my
family and my son is a physics teacher
too so I feel very close to physicist
well we're in a I suppose of the tea
room in the physics department and I've
actually given a talk in here I can't
remember what it was about to some
visiting delegation anyway this is what
I want to show you it's a black board
which was written on by Einstein when
Einstein came to visit Nottingham in the
1930s on the 6th of June 1930 even in
the 19th in 1930 when he came he was
really a huge personality in physics and
so they wanted to keep it and this is
part of the blackboard part of his
lecture and you can see here it is
signed a Einstein 6th of June 1930 so
they must have realized at the time that
they were going to keep this I met
somebody who told me that they lectured
that I understand gave was a complete
disaster because in those days Einstein
I didn't speak English at all all spoke
it only badly so he gave the lecture in
German and it was known it was going to
be in German so the university invited
two different sorts of students physics
students because they could understand
the physics and German students those
studying the German language because
they could understand what was being
said but it was a disaster because the
physicists couldn't understand
anything that was being said and the
German students couldn't understand the
physics so I think nobody except perhaps
the professor and some of the lecturers
who probably understood German really
knew what the lecture was about at all
well I think it's it makes me feel very
privileged to see this and to realize
that even famous scientists like
Einstein couldn't really use the
blackboard very clearly and so I might
have had difficulty to follow the
lecture but I would probably be among
those who preserve understood the German
but not the physics do you speak German
D yes I worked in Germany for a few
months I don't speak German very well
but enough to follow lectures well go on
then tell me what what's on there I
think it says units unified field theory
here
I think that it is absolutely great that
my colleagues here in physics have the
same sort of enthusiasm for their
subject that we do in chemistry and the
first few videos are really quite
exciting I've been watching them instead
of doing my work and I hope you'll do
the same yes always carried around with
me just in case I need it
yep yeah very handy if you're doing if
you're stuck in a in a delayed train or
okay it's a nice balance
gravitational lensing is the tool that
lets us measure its mass so we don't
have to touch anything we're using
basically a magnet to move the sample in
now we can come back again here I think
I'm good to get run over in a minute
I've now actually read the explanation
here and know what this blackboard is
this is what I would call the sort of
menu at the beginning of the lecture the
different points that Einstein was going
to go through in his lecture so probably
he had this on one side and said another
board way he was doing the maths and
then he would come back and say now to
point number three and so on and that's
probably where it was preserved what do
you think that's worth I have no idea I
probably not very much remem but I think
I think it is more of sentimental value
and then monetary value there is some
quite nice stories here as well that
somebody took the piece of chalk that
Einstein had used and broke it in half
and gave half to the university and kept
the other half for himself it also says
that Einstein borrowed five pounds from
somebody five pounds in those days was a
lot of money it was a whole week salary
for a lecturer perhaps even more but he
forgot to give it back and there is a
letter here from his wife saying I'm
really sorry that my husband
doesn't deal with money and sorry you
haven't had the money and so I've now
arranged to have it transferred and it
should be coming soon I must say that I
can't remember any lecturers ever coming
in recent times and demanding money but
doubtless with the recession that this
might happen